ah dolphins very jumpy very spinny but
not all dolphins get to just fart around
all the time in the open ocean because
this is a river and this year is the
aptly named river dolphin of the Amazon
it's the largest river dolphin in the
world measuring up to 8 feet long and
it's specially adapted to this unique
environment because the river dolphin
doesn't have as much wiggle room as its
cousins out at sea
it's especially maneuverable unlike
other dolphins its neck vertebrae aren't
fused so it can turn its head and be all
like say what the river dolphin also has
an enlarged fluke an fins for better
steering check out its dorsal thing
namely it doesn't really exist that may
be an adaptation to allow the dolphin to
spin in shallow waters also notice the
Dolphins big-ass head that's a clue that
it sends up echolocation is highly
developed I mean look at the water here
eyesight can be worthless this river
needs a filter but then again murky
water is good for private time alright
take it easy you too